[MUSIC]
I would say there's two clear signs that
would indicate when a conflict is
about to become a negative conflict for
the team or for the business.
The first sign that a conflict is going to
become a negative force in your team,
is if the emotions are starting to
escalate.
If people are getting angry or if they're
getting upset.
This is a sign that the conflict is going
to become personal,
is going to become distracting from task
performance.
The second sign that a conflict is going
to be destructive for a team, is that
people are fighting about things that they
actually don't really care about or
shouldn't be that important.
So, if your fighting about something very
silly about what time to meet or
who's gonna do what.
Often these types of conflicts are venues
for people to fight about bigger issues.
Be it status concerns, leadership issues,
questions of respect.
If you're fighting about something that
you just doesn't make sense,
why this is such a big issue, that often
means that your team is in trouble and
this is a destructive conflict.
And they need to take a step back to
figure out, what the real issues are and
go from there.
[MUSIC]
Conflicts generally start with one person
who's listening to a group discussion and
thinks gee, I really don't agree with what
is being said here.
I should say something.
So, the person expresses conflict, and the
other people on the team have
the choice to reflect on that and to offer
feedback to agree or disagree.
Generally, one person will offer feedback
to what the person says, so you think we
should take strategy x, well actually I
think we should take strategy y.
At this point you have an interpersonal
conflict between two people on the team.
The other five team members could be
sitting there watching and
deciding whether or not they should choose
to engage or not.
Conflicts at this stage generally are the
most positive for
team performance, because the two people
engaging,
are engaging because of authentic interest
in the issue, and
differences in opinion are information and
they need to be reconciled.
However, as the conflict starts to
escalate and
to grow and to involve more members,
members may not always join.
For reasons due to the, the question being
fought about,
they could join because they get
emotional,
if people are starting to yell or get
angry and they also get emotional.
Could also be that they're helping
political alliances their boss, or
their friend or someone they're close to
is involved in the conflict, and
they feel they may need to join to support
them.
This is a second phase of conflict and
where subgroups start to form.
And when the subgroup's involved in a
conflict, again it intensifies, it
escalates, it's more likely to become more
personal and destructive than the initial
conflict between the two people, who had
just different pieces of information.
And as these subgroups start to fight with
one another over time,
any remaining members that weren't
involved in the conflict have no choice.
They're going to be sucked in as well and
then you have a true team brawl,
which is not going to be a good thing for
team performance.
[MUSIC]
If a manager detects a conflict in the
team, the first thing the manager should
do is to identify what's being discussed
and who's involved and why.
So, if he sees two members, or she sees
two members discussing an issue that's
very related to the task and the members
seem to be engaging in this debate.
Because they want to make the team better.
As a manager, this is a conflict that you
should allow to go out.
Just let it play out and to see where they
come to in this conflict.
However, if the manager knows that the
conflict is personal or emotional or
it's about issues that are not so
important, such as about the process,
this is a conflict that you should cut off
and try to resolve offline.
Talk to the members individually, try to
get them on the same page again.
So that would be the first step, is to
understand what they're fighting about,
what their motivations are, and then to
deal with that.
[MUSIC]
So, task conflicts are, again, the most
productive form of conflict in teams.
And there's three other forms of conflict
that can occur in teams and
are generally likely to hurt team
performance.
These three destructive types of conflict
in teams are process conflicts,
relationship conflicts, and status
conflicts.
Process conflicts are conflicts about a
logistics, of day to day working themes.
Of what time we're gonna meet,
who's gonna do what, what responsibilities
each person should have.
These conflicts interestingly have been
shown to be the most negative form of
conflict that can occur in teams.
The reason being is that these conflicts
often represent underlying issues
in the team.
That if you're gonna fight about roles and
responsibilities, it's often because you
care about your status or
your prestige in the team, but you're
unwilling to say that.
So, then you choose indirectly to choose
the best responsibility for
yourself to gain prestige over your
teammates.
This makes these types of conflicts
particularly dangerous.
Relationship conflicts are another
negative form of conflict in teams.
Relationship conflicts about personality
clashes,
differences in political beliefs, people
who just don't get along.
These conflicts have always shown to be
negative for
team performance and are best avoided if
you can.
The last type of conflict,
that's been more recently pointed out in
the literature, is status conflicts, or
conflicts about the relative respect the
people have for
on another within the team.
About the hierarchy, about the rank order.
These types of conflicts are especially
prevalent in higher level teams in
the organizations.
There are teams where people really care
about stages in power.
Some management teams, boards of
directors, et cetera.
This conflicts are particularly difficult
to work with and
often negative performance because people
often don't voice them directly.
As indirect behaviors, it's engaging in
process conflicts to claim a choice
responsibility to improve your status, as
a gauge in a relationship conflicts to
derogate somebody to again prove, improve
your own position.
And because status conflicts are so
insidious, they're very difficult to catch
and very difficult to resolve.
And so, if there's any way to get the team
on the same page to avoid status issues in
the first place, a manager will be well
advised to do that.
[MUSIC]
One of the solutions in the literature
that's been looked at then is,
how do you help virtual teams?
Given that virtual teams have more issues
with conflict than face to face teams.
And one main solution is to make sure that
you have a face to face kick off,
when you start working together with a
virtual team.
This is really critical,
to give team members a few days together
to get to know one another.
So, they have a context and
an understanding of the relationship and
of the person.
In case they do have a conflict over email
or
over the phone, they know how to make
sense of it and
to make the right attributions, rather
than taking things personally.
[MUSIC]
If conflict isn't managed and isn't dealt
with, and
it transforms into a negative form of
conflict, be it process conflict,
relationship conflict, status conflict, it
can tear a team to pieces.
There's been research that shows that
conflict leads to
psychosomatic complaints.
People get burnout, they get depressed,
they leave the company, and
the teams eventually can dissolve.
So, the dangers of not resolving conflicts
are huge.
It's something managers really do need to
take seriously in the daily life of their
teams is to monitor their conflicts and
prevent them from getting to that point.
[MUSIC]
My top three tips for managing conflict in
an organization include.
Knowing what people are fighting about,
why they're fighting, and
at what are their emotions while they're
fighting.
So, to discuss each of these three points
in a little bit more detail,
first understand what they're fighting
about, what's the topic of the conflict?
Is it about the goals of the team?
Or is it about something that's not likely
to help your team so much, such as
questions of logistics, interpersonal
tensions, status concerns, et cetera?
So recognize what the topic of the
conflict is and make choices accordingly.
Secondly, understand the motivations of
why people are engaged in a conflict.
Is what they're fighting about the real
issue?
Are there issues under the surface the
people are trying to indirectly raise in
another manner?
Such as, you know, are they engaging in a
process conflict about what time to meet,
as a way to further their own status
position in the team?
And to have strategies ready to resolve
these underlying issues.
So, recognize why they're engaging, and
make sure you deal with the conflict,
at that level, rather than, necessarily,
at the surface level.
Finally, to look at the emotions.
And to monitor the emotions carefully
during conflicts, the minute that
members start to become emotional, to be
upset, to raise their voices.
This conflict is no longer gonna be good
for performance and the team needs to take
a break, you need to step in to resolve it
one on one with members individually, or
find a way out of the situation before it
escalates out of control.
[MUSIC]